wait a morning say four or five we got
to talk about what's happening in
Chicago
everybody's watching this viral video
this guy in a hoodie they're calling the
Grim Reaper
stop the car jacket is the rightful
taking the law into its own hands he's
become a folk hero what about the
shooter it was like a white dude
when they needed me most I want what if
your emergencies men are breaking into
my house kisses are here to protect them
the men who did are out there
so the nothing that you can do is that
what you said if a man really wants to
protect horses I want to buy a gun he
has to do is for himself we're close pal
look you like white who else is there
I don't know anything else I'll believe
it Joe so you're not gonna kill me no
Jagger's
you got caught in crossfire ice cream
underneath the ice cream can't walk to
school if they don't work for you were
you the last customer you're cocked
locked and ready to work
don't say they called him beside an
angel he's my life
[Music]
you look much better
getting out socializing hmm not so much
well whatever you're doing keep it up
okay I will
[Music]
you